you have a friendship with elon musk uh
often when i talk to him he'll bring up
how incredible of an engineer and just a
big picture
thinker you are his a huge amount of
respect uh for you
i just
i've never been a fly in the wall
between a discussion between the two of
you i just wonder is there something you
guys
debate argue about discuss is there some
interesting problems that the two of you
think about
you come from different worlds maybe
there's some intersection
in the in aerospace maybe there's some
intersection
in your new efforts in artificial
intelligence in terms of thinking is
there something interesting you could
say about sort of the debates the two of
you have so i think in some ways we do
have a kind of similar background where
we're almost exactly the same age and we
had kind of similar programming
backgrounds on the personal computers
and you know even some of the the books
that we would read and things that would
kind of turn us into the people that we
are today
and i think there is a degree of
sensibility similarities where you know
we kind of call [ __ ] on the same
things and kind of see the same uh
opportunities in different technology
and there's that sense of you know i
always talk about the speed of light
solutions for things and he's thinking
about kind of minimum manufacturing and
engineering and
operational standpoints for things
and
so i mean i first met elon right at the
start of the aerospace era where i
wasn't familiar with uh and i was still
in my game dev bubble i really wasn't
familiar with all the startups that were
going and being successful and what went
on with paypal and all of his different
companies but you know i met him as i
was starting to do armadillo aerospace
and you know he came down with kind of
his right hand propulsion guy and we we
talked about rockets you know what can
we what can we do with this and it was
kind of specific things about like how
are how are our flight computers set up
what are different propellant options i
am you know what can happen with
different uh different ways of putting
things together
and then
in some ways he was certainly the
biggest player in the sort of alt space
community that was going on in the early
2000s
he was
the most well funded although you know
his funding in the larger scheme of
things compared to a
like a nasa or something like that was
really tiny uh it was a lot more than i
had at the time
i
but it was interesting i had a point
years later when i realized okay my like
my financial resources at this point are
basically what elon's was when he went
all in on spacex and tesla
and there's
i i think in many corners he does not
get uh the respect that he should about
being a wealthy person that could just
retire and he went all in where he was
really going to i
you know he could have gone bust and
there's plenty of people you look at the
you know the sad uh athletes or or
entertainers that had all the money in
the world and blew it he could have been
the the business case example of that
but i
you know the the things that he was
doing space exploration electrification
of transportation uh solar city type
things these are big world level things
and i have a great deal of admiration
that he was willing to throw himself so
completely into that because in contrast
with myself i was doing armadillo
aerospace with this tightly bounded uh
it was john's crazy money at the time
that had a finite limit on it it was
never going to impact me or my family
if it completely failed and i was still
hedging my bets
working at id software at the time when
he had been you know really all in there
and i have a huge amount of respect for
that and people do not the other thing i
get irritated with is people that say
it's like oh elon's just just a business
guy you know he just got like he was
gifted the money and he's just kind of
uh investing in all of this when uh he
was really deeply involved in a lot of
the decisions you know
not all of them were perfect but i you
know he cared very much about engine
material selection propellant selection
and i you know for years he'd be kind of
telling me it's like get off that
hydrogen peroxide stuff it's like you
know liquid oxygen is the you know it's
the only proper oxidizer for this
and i am you know unlike the times that
i've gone through the factories with him
we're we're talking very detailed things
about like how this weld is made you
know how this sub assembly goes together
i you know what are like startup
shutdown behaviors of the different
things so he is you know really
in there at a very detailed level and i
think that he is the the best modern
example now of someone that tries to
that can effectively micromanage some
decisions on things on both tesla you
know and spacex to some degree where he
cares enough about it i worry a lot that
he stretched too thin that you get
boring company and neuralink and twitter
and all the other possible things there
where i know i've got i
i've got limits on how much i can pay
attention to uh that i have to kind of
box off different amounts of time
and i look back at like at my aerospace
side of things it's like i did not go
all in on that i did not commit myself
at a level that it would have taken to
be successful there
and
i
yeah and it's kind of a weird thing just
uh like having a a discussion with he's
the richest man in the world right now
but he i you know he operates on you
know on a level that is still
uh very much in my wheelhouse on a
technical side of things
you